welcome to this video playing ulysses s
grant yeah well probably not the real
ulysses s grant unless there's something
really fishy going on okay well i played
before yeah yeah d 5 is the most
principled line but i really have no
idea how to play this okay i'm playing
in a somewhat more passive fashion here
check not liking that too much but d 5 I
really remember that i had had played
this before the third g5 and i got
really really punished for not knowing
the theoretical details I'm just trying
to play this like as image maybe maybe
it's it's not not too bad
okay now i have actually overlooked this
d takes d5 I thought Fe 95 this is nice
okay well it's not it's not the end of
the world the structure at least them
it's not so clear what this Bishop is
doing at f5 well if I've hangs and 19
i-g 3 to 5 m9 3325 this is a problem a
substantial problem even hmm how to play
interesting Queen Queen e6 to see for
something like that the light squares of
course our eyes problem but also mine
yeah port g6 is very very ugly chest
yeah I'll Knight a5 I cannot tolerate
really cannot hidden yeah this will be
will be difficult pretty sure pretty
difficult defense yeah his maybe just
going for Queen to g4 I wonder ever
should play Queen age form yeah come on
let's cover this is this important
attacking square F 595 still
yam the night on a five ism is not
playing night c4 maybe at some sometimes
honestly six you know I think the
position is not so clear it's not so
clear it looks like white should get
some some kind of a tech but the
position also has some drawbacks f5 is
not easily playable general this odd
always rent runs into this Bishop f2
that's 94 and I don't mind so much that
the Snyder's may be exchanging on III
it's a not such a great empty one may be
roped you on him rock d one night rock
fd1 yeah look ft 193 route 37 this might
be might be an idea and okay I can we
treat to see file maybe but this is an
interesting I an interesting play look
Timon and Phi had on the clock oh that's
good news
rook be 21 I think I'll just take these
three Queen takes a drug the aid you
have 93 comintex hook the end this looks
like a relatively simple enter okay
solution where is it going not clear now
see 495 is nice but it gives away the
default square and that's really a
problem
hmm
Queen Queen h6 would threaten 95 is one
of those neat tricks okay it's a it's a
trick let's try it for that okay yeah
still at 5i have 95 so not much of a
problem
still I'm not sure maybe maybe really
here to attack e5 with the Queen and try
to with night f82 to initiate some
exchanges getting walks off are
interesting move didn't see that at all
okay well whoopty 67 I thought I can I
that's it sits slightly tricky but I
think I can do that d7 Queen f65 or not
yeah f5 and then 97 others should we
should be quite solid mostly because
it's not only to was really a miserable
piece now yeah i was just about I just
wanted to suggest this moves the only
way to really get this night going
Queen f7 takes Queen takes Knight g3
look check sir for this playable looks a
bit shaky
I wanted to get 36 born once and for all
okay yeah
keeping pieces on the board
Luke yet I cannot play I'm such an idiot
no rookie aid what an idea ah come on
this is idiotic time morning this was
terrible terrible really boo check check
check check check check check check
check mate Wow I'm very lucky at the
moment I'm very very lucky yeah I don't
know around here this this must be must
be very good for black I'm just not
finding the right move here yeah only
0.5 then then here's the problem not
sure Queen Queen D 727s winning or Queen
f7 yeah I don't need to and it I don't
need to play it right away 97 I only
need to prevent g4 ever managed to
prevent that then it's basically gone
because the night stays so bad only two
queen d 7 or Queen f7 is the 197 just
looks like the obvious move but it's not
it's not the best one this is the real
real thing attacking attacking the night
this is much much better now on Queen
and King
you have to i can i can play like that
and this is just very good for my much
better than the game yeah and this this
already is tricky could have taken c6
even better and here i just played
plated really badly i thought my first
idea was g5 then I then I saw Oh Queen
III how do I even tell her that and then
my idea was after this to play em to
play 98 and 98 is of course not working
at all I mean I'm just losing here
Knight a5 did it all wins and if she
simply blundered the Queen IAM and only
had chatting seconds now okay i somehow
managed was very very lucky around here
it was it was an interesting position
probably probably probably about about
equal I thought I maybe have something
but it's difficult based on this
somewhat clumsy know it but how do I get
hurt here so difficult maybe maybe Queen
Queen age six kind of a DM wasn't wasn't
the best yeah this kind of middle game
is very very complicated and hard too
hard to play with little time it's very
double-edged because both sides have
their have the problems in the position
alright thanks for watching